tech billionaire elon musk is a
visionary who dreams of moving to mars
he isn't just one of the planet's
richest people he's one of its biggest
recipients of government handouts
according to lisa conyers and phil
harvey
authors of welfare for the rich how your
tax dollars end up in millionaires
pockets and what you can do about it
by 2015 companies led by musk had
already gotten
billions in subsidies tax breaks and
other handouts and he's not alone
there are thousands of other immensely
rich people
who are constantly milking the
government for special perks
carve-outs and handouts here are five of
the very worst ways they do that
since 1933 when congress passed the
first farm support bill
the government has been shoveling
billions of dollars in the form of crop
insurance cash payouts and other
subsidies to the smaller and smaller
number of american farmers
as conyers and harvey document former
obama commerce secretary
and billionaire penny pritzker received
1.6
million dollars in subsidies between
1996 and 2006
and republican south dakota governor
christie gnome is part of a family
business that got over
three million dollars in subsidies
between 1995
and 2008. because of protectionist
tariffs and price supports americans pay
around triple the world price for sugar
thanks to efforts by billionaires like
the fondue brothers alfie and pepe
dubbed the first family of corporate
welfare by time magazine
many if not most pro sports team owners
are billionaires
yet between 1997 and 2015 almost
half of all construction costs for new
nfl stadiums were covered by taxpayers
in the case of raymond james stadium
home to super bowl champs the tampa bay
buccaneers taxpayers ponied up
100 of building costs and the team
basically gets all
revenue generated at the stadium too
the walt disney corporation with a
market cap of 368 billion dollars
is the heavyweight champ among theme
park operators when it comes to
sweetheart deals
disney returned 2.3 billion dollars to
investors in 2017 alone and bob iger
chairman and ceo earns north of 45
million dollars a year
so of course disneyland located in
anaheim california needs handouts
25 years ago anaheim built disney a new
parking structure that cost 108 million
dollars
and then lease it back to the company
for the high price of a dollar a year
in 2015 the city agreed to exempt the
park from paying entertainment taxes for
45 years and in 2016 it agreed to a 650
million dollar tax rebate
on a luxury hotel that disney built near
the happiest place on earth
over the past decade peabody the largest
private coal company in the world
pulled in around 275 million dollars in
state and federal subsidies while
generating 5.6
billion dollars in revenue in 2017.
exelon a power company that specializes
in nuclear energy
generated 34 billion dollars in revenue
in 2017
the year after it gold new york state
into giving it 7.6 billion dollars to
keep four
aging and underperforming nuclear power
plants going
a few years back new york state shelled
out 750 million dollars to build a
factory for elon musk's renewable energy
company solar city
then they said the company would pay no
property taxes for a decade
saving them another 260 million dollars
but as conyers and harvey argue in our
new information-rich world
citizen activists are fighting back in
louisiana when one group learned that
exxon and other gas and oil companies
were getting away without paying
property taxes
it led to a new public accountability
law they also point to websites that
track
subsidies and handouts empowering
citizens to protest the use of tax
dollars to guilt the pockets of mega
corporations and the billionaires who
own them if and when
elon musk actually makes it to mars
let's make sure he buys his own ticket
you